good morning everyone good morning hope
things are uh
okay looks like it's going to rain today
which is um
i guess that's okay the flowers need it
somebody needs it
so uh welcome to our uh
exec session this morning um
i will uh
call on uh representative emrick
to go through the
division one bills
thank you madam chair uh the first bill
we have is
senate bill 227 it came to us
by and large complete except that we we
did amend it
to add corrections officers which is
starting on line 16
so we didn't have an amendment to the
bill
other than that it's already unchanged
i'd ask representative griffin to speak
to any other changes
yes
the amendment uh
as parole officers and certain other
class two
employees
we heard testimony from the uh
from the public and the professionals
that suicide was
quite
often rare it wasn't
a normal thing it may be a
less than a half a dozen a year
in the worst case scenario
and we also
felt that adding a few employees as
parole offices and things would
not likely have a major impact on the
bill so all in all
uh division one supported the bill with
the amendment
thank you are there are there any
questions
seeing none um
could i have a motion to accept the
amendment
uh two two zero two two one three three
zero
thank you a second
thank you
all those in favor please raise your
hand
opposed
okay
two obstac
and one abstention
uh
call on tracy for
an ought to pass as amended
on sb 227
representative griffin would make that
motion
i move that
we accept
senate bill 227 as amended
thank you who is that
thank you
well the clerk please call the roll
thank you madam chair
representative weiler
yes
president of the burj yes president
impeach of ots
representative emerick yes
representative irf epstein
representative griffin yes
representative edwards
abstain epstein
representative bean
representative lynn
now
representative mooney yes
representative uh
walner
yes
not here
i was in puko
rozano schultz
yes
representative hatch
representative walsh
yes
representative heath
representative murray
yes
there was an umberger
madam chair madam chair
yes representative turcotte was not
called representative votes no did i
miss that
arizona church on
no
representative nordgren
i'm
oh you are here okay i'm sorry
representing norgrin yes or we're going
to have to get a new clerk
all right one two three
15 in the affirmative
three in a negative two abstentions
per amendment 2 20 22 13 30 h
the motion passes
on sb2
uh will there be a minority report
representative bean or turcotte
can i get back to you on that
i'm going to put it in this report yeah
about 9 30.
about 9 30. tell you about 9 30.
no it'll be fine just let us know after
the uh okay thank you there is a
minority report well it's not sure
he hasn't made up his mind okay
all right we now turn to sb 371
uh
representative emrick thank you madam
chair deferred to representative griffin
yes
can we understand why these people
abstain because usually you only stand
if you have a conflict of interest and
it's not clear to me why there were two
abstentions
represented earth has a conflict of
interest
my wife's an emt
representative edwards
i don't care to share the reasons
okay
representative griffin
thank you madam chair
this bill makes a three million dollar
appropriation to the
lead paint hazard fund
administrated by the housing authority
the fund is used to provide
interest-free loans
to owners of rental units
for
lead paint remuneration
in order to protect young children
living in those rental units
the program has been a great success
with over 860 rented units
completed to date
however those loans are payable when
title to the building changes
so the fund is at this point depleted
and this appropriation would add to the
fund
so they could continue the outstanding
work they're doing
thank you are there any questions
i'd ask for a motion please
madam chair i move that we accept uh
senate bill 371.
do i have a second
second by representative heath
ready
will the clerk please call the roll
thank you madam chair um
revenue willer yes
representative burris yes
arizona petri votes yes representative
emerick yes
representative earth yes
representative griffin yes
representative edwards
yes
representative bean
representative lynn
no
rosanna mooney
yes
representative turcotte yes
representative walner
yes
i was in an organ
representative puko yes
i was under shoals yes
representative hatch
representative walsh
yes
representative heath
representative murray yes
representative umberger
yes madam chair the vote is 19 to 1 in
the affirmative
for sb 371
the vote being 19 to 1 sb 371 passes
uh will there be a minority report no
no
okay thank you
it's got money
i would love to put it on consent i'd
love to put all these on consent but
i don't
i'm afraid
paul wouldn't allow it
so
okay
uh moving on to sb
fn
relative to broadband matching grant
initiative
representative emrick
thank you madam chair
i have an amendment to this
bill
uh
actually the bill came to us
with this amendment
accompanying it having not been passed
by the senate
there was a request that we initiate
this amendment the only change from what
came to us from the senate is on line 11
is the word and the amendment is the
word successfully
challenges
that's the only thing that
changed from the senate version
beyond that i'd look to representative
griffin to fill in the blank spots
on the basis representative griffin
thank you madam chair
senate bill 445 makes an
uh appropriation of 122 million 100 000
in federal funds authorized by
the american relief plan rescue act of
the funds to be transferred from the u.s
treasury
to the broadband matching grant fund
established under
rsa
12-0
colon 63.
the bill also sets up guidelines for a
matching grant program in a men's
rsa
12-0
colon 63 by increasing
the eligible grant from
50 percent to 75 of the total eligible
project
costs
that's
really what the bill does is raises
the eligible
costs from 50 percent to 75
the finance
committee voted to pass the bill
thank you um
are there any questions
okay we will
need a motion on the amendment
which is 2022-1537h
representative griffin
uh shall move man thank you do i have a
second
i'll second it since it was mine okay
representative emmerich
all those in favor of the amendment
please raise your hand
opposed
uh the amendment passes
now i need a motion on
sb
445 as amended madam chair
i move uh senate bill 445
with the amendment as octopaths
ought to pass as amended thank you do i
have a second
representative heath thank you
will the clerk call the role madam sure
yes i'd like to could i speak to this
place yes you have a question or comment
certainly yes thank you very much
um
i do not support this bill and i'm going
to explain why during our hearing
uh it was told to us that there are only
approximately 21 000 individuals in the
entire state that do not
have access
to this to broadband
um it was also brought up somebody
mentioned the fact that wireless
satellite
and all those technologies are coming up
now when you when you look at 122
million dollars
for 21 000 potential customers not all
of those would take that
you're looking at a cost of over six
thousand dollars for potential household
to me that's just a an extraordinarily
poor way of spending this money whether
it's considered free from the federal
government and not
so i will be uh voting against thank you
madam chair
represent emrick would you like to uh
respond to that please
oh representative hatch i'm sorry
we did we asked that question
uh and it got into the debate of the
last mile
and who how how expensive the last mile
really is
several things came up one is the
definition of uh
under construction
in this industry actually negotiating
for polls to hang the lines on is
considered under construction
that's where this challenge for a
successful challenge came from
the other issue had to do with who takes
care of them once they're installed
because the bill didn't specify that and
in fact once a line goes live with a
carrier say it's a con comcast becomes
the provider on that line they're
responsible for maintenance that from
that point on
but as far as the the cost
uh
that it's very expensive the last mile
is very expensive
thank you for that exponent oh
i'm sure
thank you for the explanation that you
i'm aware of those that
really doesn't address the initial
my initial point
which is i'm not asking a question i'm
making the point that this is an
extremely expensive
and i think unwise way to spend 122
million dollars thank you
representative hatch
thank you madam chair
representative emmerich made most of my
points but so
27 000 individuals sounds de minimis
compared to the overall population of
the state but consider this please uh
almost one third of the state
encompasses thirteen thousand people
just keep that in mind thank you
mountain chair
you wouldn't be referring to colas
county would you
[Laughter]
it's all separate
i didn't get the landmass size of coast
it's big
representative
thank you madam chair uh yeah i'm being
from coast uh
it is the the largest county not only
that but
the most rural
county in all of the state so
the last mile is expensive because the
towns and homes are extremely
you know spread out
so that's why i think the bill is
necessary to do at least
you know wire the people um
so that we can get things done properly
we have a lot of we have uh 23
unincorporated places
most of them aren't occupied but at
least you know this bill would help
connect people in remote areas so i'm in
favor of the bill
is there any further
discussion
sorry represent
edwards
following up kind of on representative
turcotte's comment um
it seems to me that a hundred percent of
the people uh whose houses are going to
be affected by this
bought their house
knowing what the internet uh
connectivity was
uh and because we have federal money
we're going to go ahead and spend it in
a profligate way
and maybe maybe we should do that but
this is a little bit like
somebody buying a house next to an
airport
and then having federal money to move
to move the airport uh it's it's it's
pretty much equivalent to that so
i'm um
i'm conflicted about voting for this um
you know because i think property owners
know what they're buying when they buy
it
representative hatch
thank you i do not desire to belabor
this but let me just point out this
that where i live
a proponent of the people bought their
houses
long before the internet existed just
just a point thank you
thank you madam chairs um
i'm a sub and the newbie so i i
appreciate your allowing me to speak
i'll be brief
i mean the point of the ara funds from
the federal government
was because correct me if i'm wrong
during covid people needed access to
the internet where they were for their
kids
or if they're teachers to teach those
or if they are workers that were
sent away from their office
regardless of your views of covet that
is what happened
and this
had been an item that many of us
regardless of if we're from coast or not
felt that our entire state
to move forward in this economy needs to
have
that level of access
so
we can have a better shot at various
businesses to attract businesses small
business big businesses but really
this came out of the immense need
for children kids and workers to have
access to their workplace in their
schools
i belie i do believe
thank you very much
for their comments
well the clerk please call the roll
thank you madam chair
representative weiler yes
representative burrage yes
representative petri volch yes
representative emery yes
representative irf yes
representative griffin yes
president of edwards yes
representative bean
representative lynn yes
representative mooney
yes
original chair caught no
president of uh
whoops
representative walner
yes
arizona norgrin yes
representative bucco yes
arizona schultz yes
president of hatch yes
it was on the walls yes
president of heath yes representative
murray yes
representative umberger yes
madam chair
uh sb 445 as amended
passes
19 to 1.
thank you the vote on sb 445
as amended is 19 to 1.
call me
we now turn to um
[Music]
division two bills
sb 402
and i would like to
turn it over to
um
actually we should probably have a
sorry uh could i have um
an open uh yeah
can i have a motion please
motion um
i move uh sb 402 amendment there's no
amendment there's no amendment
oh yes
sorry
right
i move uh amendment one five seven eight
twenty twenty two
one five seven eight okay thank you
and let me see
i can't get my paper straight
yeah it's here
see this is the
this is the uh loan right
okay
go ahead
uh the amendment um
to sb402 is um
made some changes dealing with the um
of um
amount of money that the um
yeah disaster
yeah on the non-federal chair this is um
after
the um it's not the longest this is
after the uh
emergency management
has
figured out what is eligible and what is
not eligible
and this allows
the
communities to
apply for state aid
in the amount not to exceed
of the non-federal share
so fema traditionally had been
a
2575 match
and with this
amendment
we are providing the opportunity
for communities
to
apply to the state
for
uh
half
of whatever
the fema
local match is
so
in the past um
the state used to provide
all of the um
the non the the non-federal match
uh but that
went away several years ago
and what we are doing here
actually in reaction to um
what happened in cheshire and sullivan
county
um
that
we're asking for
uh
the state to consider
okay consider
approving
half of the
non-federal match
i think that covers it it does
okay madam chair
yes i make the motion to pass
amendment
2022-1578-h okay do i have a second
second
representative earth no representative
lynn
oh was lynn yeah well you're pretty loud
back to you
yes i see representative irf
thank you madam chair may i just ask for
a clarification
my understanding was
the fema part is split 75 25
but that this did not apply to any of
that
this applied to anything in excess of
no
this just applies to the
the match
fema puts in some amount
okay
and this only applies to the non-fema
money
what the
communities would have to pay
and we also if you notice in there that
um
the um
homeland our our homeland security
area
will be
managing this
grant program could i ask one more
question surely so just to be sure i
understand to the extent that
the cost of the disaster exceeds the
state plus the
federal share of the fema portion to
extent that exceeds that fema
calculation that the local community
will be picking up that that excess
that's correct thank you
this is only for
fema approved
repairs
or whatever
representative thank you madam chair um
just for those who weren't in division
two during the discussion on this bill
and uh the next one we will be talking
about
the for me and much of the discussion on
this particular bill came down to the
the difference between whether it was a
grant
or a loan and as we get into the next
bill you will see that one uh talks
about loans
and some of the discussion on this
because it is a grant rather than
um alone
um there were concerns about the
political
implications you know in certain times
is is one person gonna uh
well is one party going to allow a
municipality to receive money or are
they not the other big thing was
mitigation
we talked about uh
nationally some of the the same places
that
receive disaster relief over and over
and over again without mitigating the
underlying condition
and by going to a grant rather than loan
um
that you we may put ourselves in the
situation of there's not quite as
um it doesn't become
mitigation doesn't become quite as
important if you're just receiving a
grant from the state
so on this particular bill i will vote
against it knowing that we do have
another bill that we've worked
on coming up that talks about disaster
relief in the form of loans thank you
madam chair
are there any further comments
represent lynn yeah i i want to say i i
um i i initially
uh i i shared the concerns that that
representative turcotte
raised but i
i really think that the way this um uh
grant proposal has been drafted it
really is fairly limited i mean if i
understand it correctly basically you're
saying the most that the grant could be
would be 12 and a half percent of what
the
total fema
award was
um and i think uh and and and it's not
that this is not
an entitlement to a grant it just says
you can apply for it and the governor
and council and the fiscal committee
have to approve so i think with those
limit to all those limitations i'm i'm
comfortable with uh with the way this is
worded
okay sorry for my confusion we uh we
were kind of interchanging 402 and 409
the whole
in our in our whole discussion um
and uh
we knew that one was a grant one was
alone and
that's
that's kind of where we uh where we
got a lot confused on uh
on what we were doing
uh but
i do believe that um
homeland security knows that we
are very much
concerned about hazard mitigation
and uh we also know that in order to
qualify i guess is the right term
for fema money you have to have a hazard
mitigation
plan
and um
you have to be
from homeland security you will have to
be making progress on that mitigation so
um
it's
whatever
okay
are there any further questions on the
amendment represent mooney thank you
madam chair just to make an observation
it seems as though reading this
amendment it is a vast improvement from
the original bill in terms of clarity so
i will be voting in favor of the
amendment
thank you i think uh division two would
agree
with that
are there any further questions or
comments on the amendment
saying none
all those
uh in favor of amendment
two zero two two
one
five seven eight
please raise your hand
did you i have a question was there a
second to to the motion yes it was uh
representing lynn
okay
unanimous
all right
uh could i have a motion please on uh
sb 402
ought to pass as amended
thank you
represent petrie do i have a second
second
thank you
yes representative
clerk call the roll please
thank you madam chair
representative wilder yes
president of the burj yes
there's an impetery vote yes
representative emerick yes
representative earth yes
representative griffin yes
representative edwards yes
representative bean
representative lynn yes
representative mooney
yes
arizona turcotte no
representative walner
yes
there's an organ yes
representative bucco yes
representative schultz
yes
arizona patch yes
representative walsh yes arizona keith
yes
representative murray yes
representative umberger
yes
madam chair of the vote on 2022
uh 1578 h
and
the full bill sp 402 passes 19 to 1.
thank you
we'll now turn to
sb
and um i will
i will call on
representative heath
do you say me
no he
thank you madam chair i think wait just
a moment
i think i need a uh
yeah motion on um
amendment
zero
two zero two two 1546
and
i would like to move that amendment
ought to pass
the second
check okay
the amendment we're just voting on the
amendment yes amendment again i'm sorry
yeah
and i'd like to speak to my amendment
hero
and peace
good
please go ahead all right thank you
madam chair
um
amendment 1546h
really i think we worked very hard on it
and it um
in response to a lot of questions and
concerns
um
409 immediately talks to
a a disaster so what our amendment does
um it it defines on who's eligible
um and the
municipality would um
relief projects shall equal or exceed 25
of an amount raised by local property
taxes the amendment goes on to say the
municipality shall not knowingly request
a disaster relief loan for costs not
eligible for reimbursement under the
fema public assistant
the amendment continues to say
recipients of an exceptional disaster
relief loan
shall be responsible to repay the entire
loan amount to the state
if the amount of the fema assistance
is less
then the this amendment allows the
municipality to work with the state
and government council to negotiate the
terms of the
difference and to negotiate a payment
plan
the amendment also goes on to talk about
the municipality shall consider applying
for
available hazard mitigation grant
funding administered by the
the division of homeland security and
emergency management that would reduce
the impact of future disasters on
facilities that were repaired with
exceptional disaster relief loan funds
municipalities must demonstrate progress
toward
implementation of their hazard
mitigation plan in order to be eligible
for future assistance loans under this
section for disasters affecting
facilities where an exceptional disaster
relief loan was previously granted thank
you madam chair
thank you are there further comments
okay uh seeing none
all those in favor of amendment 2022
please raise your hand
opposed
thank you
uh could i please have a motion uh ought
to pass
on sb 409. so moved madame chair thank
you representative turcotte second by uh
representative heath
yeah oh
did we get through the a otpa
yeah
thank you
will the clerk please call the roll
thank you madam chair uh
this is on
senate bill 409 as amended
ought to pass
representative weiler yes
president the burroughs yes
representative petrie of lgs
representative emerick yes
president earth yes
representative griffin yes
representative edwards yes
representative bean
representative blinn yes
representative mooney
yes
representative yes
representative walner
yes
representative norgren yes
representative bucco yes alexander
schultz yes
representative hatch yes
representative walsh yes
representative heath yes
president murray yes and representative
volberger
yes i don't share the vote on sb 409 as
amended is 20 to 0.
any affirmative
uh thank you
um
does anyone have any problem with
putting 402
and 409 on the consent calendar
since there's no direct money
associated with it i think we can
do that
pardon
well since there's no appropriation tied
to this bit to these two bills
i think we can go on the consent
calendar
okay
okay with no objection we will put those
on consent
okay we now turn to
um
sb 412
and there is an amendment um
representative
edwards
madam chair i i move amendment uh 1582
to sb 412 and i'm prepared to speak to
the amendment
okay i need a second
second
representative
okay go ahead
thank you madam chair um
this amendment uh attempts to clean up
some miscues that happened during the
budgeting process
there was absolutely no doubt that the
both houses the senate and the house
wanted to increase nursing home
reimbursement rates by five percent
effective uh july 1 of uh 2021.
apparently raising
reimbursement rates
is a dark art that's very complicated
and
so
what
we thought we had done we actually
failed to achieve uh there wasn't enough
money
available to
to cover the five percent so so since
these things get adjusted quarterly
there was a
first quarter adjustment
and a second quarter adjustment and and
both of those were
significantly below the five percent
what what this bill does is it uh works
to
make good on the legislature's promise
of a five percent increase to the
nursing homes
um and uh it appropriates five million
dollars to to cover the cost of that
nursing home reimbursement rate
if we don't need all five million
dollars between now and the end of june
uh that money will
lapse but apparently because this is so
complicated to calculate reimbursement
rates it's possible that we may be
underestimating again
and so it leaves open an escape hatch
for the commissioner to write us to let
us know whether or not there's going to
be enough money to cover our promises
so
i i don't understand why it's so hard
but but that's why i'm just a legislator
and not an accountant so i
i would ask for your support on this
bill
first the amendment
i need i need to uh take a quick recess
and uh ask
representative walner edwards
and
[Music]
weiler to come in my office
please
hmm
oh
uh
oh 227
227 is 227 is
15 3 and 2 extensions
yes
nineteen to one
nineteen two three seven one
all right
and then
445 is
that's another one with abstentions
oh no
that's 19 to 1.
19 to 1.
okay
that's it so it's 15 3 and 2 19. okay
thank you sure
by the time i got here i had an idea
what i was doing was 19 yes one no
11 votes yes
maybe i still don't
can i uh you did this before right
sure
but
you you got you you got to
who said what right
yes yeah see we didn't have a whip sheet
like that we just
y and n
we're going to get these two here
extensions
so so when we get in between here if i
can talk sure
this
okay
i just um
needed a further explanation of uh of
this amendment which
seemed to me to be confusing
so
uh if i understand correctly
from our little conversation
that
the
the five the five million dollars
will only
be appropriated
if
hhs runs out of money
and they send a letter
to the
the governor
the senate president and the speaker of
the house
and then from there
the governor would draw a warrant up to
whatever the dollar value
was needed
is that
i think i think that's an accurate
summary okay
all right
uh i think this is a first time for me
to see us
asking the governor like this but
as long as this works we'll
be okay so don't ask me any questions
but uh
there are people here who can answer
questions so
are there any questions on this
amendment
yes
i'm just trying to understand have we
been paying the reimbursement at the
higher rate even though this got messed
up in the budget
uh representative edwards the uh
with the quarter that began january 1 we
we got to the 5
in the first quarter
when the this was supposed to be come
effective
i think we only were able to
through the calculations uh
generate a
rate increase of
0.2 percent and then in the third
entering the second quarter the
calculation came up to 3.8 percent
so we've been
we we're we're good now
but we had two low quarters and so
we want to go back and retroactively
fix the hole we left
i understood the only thing i would ask
is quarters and just specify the year
like you're talking about 2021
the first quarter started july 2021 of
the new budget years you're talking the
second half of 2021
that we were low
that and the reimbursement it depends on
what how important the fiscal year is to
you it's the first two quarters of the
fiscal year
okay
are there any other questions
seeing none
all those in favor of amendment 2022
1582 please raise your hand
a post
thank you
um
now could i have a motion as uh
octopass as amended on sb
four one two
i'd like to move uh
otpa for
five or four one two as amended thank
you do i have a second second second
thank you represent earth
will the clerk please call the rome
thank you madam chair this is uh sb 412
autopass as amended
with amendment 1582h
representative weiler yes
president the burris yes president petri
voce representative lynn yes
representative mooney
yes
arizona chair caught yes reginald walner
representative bucco
yes
representative norgren yes
sneaky aren't i
representative schultz yes
president of hatch yes
arizona walsh yes project heath yes
president murray yes and representative
umberger yes let him share the vote on
sb 412 as amended is 20 to zero any
affirmative
thank you
okay
um
we'll now move to sb
and we have amendment
1 3 3 1 each
madam chair i'd i'd like to move
amendment one three three one and at the
appropriate time speak to the amendment
do i have a second second
second fight representative irf
represent edwards uh thank you madam
chair um
at first glance this appears to be a
substantial amendment
um
let me let me instead of diving into the
details i'll save the details for any
questions that you may have but i just
want to back up and take a look at where
we are in the overall process
the state of new hampshire has debated
whether or not we should have an adult
dental medicaid benefit for a number of
years
in this current term
there was a
close working relationship between
the policy committee and the and the
finance committee of dhhs
we made some uh modifications to um hb
uh passed the house very successfully
and um then it
reached the senate
at the same time because this was so
important the senate sent to us
senate bill 422.
422 was slightly different in that
its benefit levels uh were a little bit
higher
they're um
but they had identified a nice source of
funding for it uh from the centene
settlement and uh they also identified
that we owed
some money um to something called a risk
corridor and it's a couple million
dollars and change
so so what what we we've done at the
request of senate bradley and in the
senate's hearing of 103
is we
simultaneously amended
hb 103
and this represents the
the um
amendment to
sb 422
so that both bills
are identical
and uh i believe senate bro senator
bradley thought this would be a good
idea to make these two bills identical
just to make sure that one of them gets
passed because we're really wanting to
get a dental medicaid benefit passed
and the
and the other reason is if the bills are
identical that that cuts down on the
whole committee a conference issue and
just lets us get this to the governor a
little bit more quickly
so um
so if there are specific questions about
the amendment i'm i'm happy to entertain
them but but the bottom line is this now
reads identical to the version that's
with the senate and h.b 103
it passed their policy committee and i
think it's going to hit the their
finance committee
this week or maybe next but
everything looks very favorable for that
so
with with that madam chair i'll i'll
take any questions if there are any
any questions on the amendment
seeing none
all those in favor of amendment one
three three three one raise your hand
unanimous
opposed
two
okay i'll entertain a motion
to pass as amended mr chair i i move
that we
do an o t p a on sb 422 using amendment
one three three one
second
and representative earth seconds
further questions seeing none are you
ready for the question
clerk will call a roll on ought to pass
as amended on senate bill 422.
thank you mr chair
uh representative wyler yes
representative burris yes
president petri volchyass representative
emerick yes
representative erf yes
arizona griffin yes representative
edwards yes arizona bean
representative lynn no
representative mooney
no
representative
representative walner
yes represent an organ
yes
representative bucco yes
representative schultz
yes
president of hatch yes
yes president heath yes
representative murray yes
uh mr chair the vote is 16-3 in
affirmative
16-3
it will go on the regular calendar
mr chairman
there there will be a minority report
represented i'll write a minority report
all right who will write it
uh
well representative lin
and what will the minority report before
uh expedient to legislate itl thank you
and mr chair the uh the committee report
in favor has uh already been turned in
good work thank you what what was the
vote on this
uh 17 to 2.
i'm sorry
i can't read my own right
uh neither can i so the amendment was 17
to 2. okay
just just so you know
i hadn't finished yet
okay
thank you representative weiler for that
um
i will do that
i move to reconsider our actions on one
to senate bill one two two uh senate
bill 227 senate bill 227
wish to have a reconsideration there is
some things we were in error on
do i have a second
yes thank you uh representative wallner
um all in favor all in favor of
reconsideration
thank you very much um
according to the clerk
we cannot have abstentions in committee
unless
you have filed a conflict of interest
statement with the clerk
if i'd only had to do that for him when
he women met on the floor he didn't make
that clear that had to be in committee
okay so i would ask
that on this bill
if those that abstained
want to vote fine
if they don't want to vote then they
should leave the room
okay then we revolt yep well the clerk
please call the roll
on uh
sb227
otpa
okay
and this is on 1330
represent water
yes
reject the burst yes
very soft-spoken
bernina petrie votes yes
representative emmerich yes
president of earth
is not here
not voting well
representative griffin
yes
representative edwards is not here
okay represent bean
representative lynn no
representative mooney
yes
president turcotte no
representative walner yes
president organ yes
roseanne bucco yes representative
schultz
yes
representative hatch yes
arizona walsh
yes
president of heath yes
representative murray yes
representative umberger
yes
madam chair the vote is 15 to 3 with two
not voting okay thank you
um
did will there be a minority report on
sb227
uh madam chair there will not be okay
thank you
and uh
you had thought maybe
you're going to have a minority report
on
he's reported 4 22.
422 will have a minority report
representative lynn will be writing that
okay thank you
sorry i was uh
out of the room
okay
um
i have all of the
majority reports in
for janet
and so i will need
the minority report
for sb 4
uh this afternoon
okay
so no problem i'll get it to you okay so
that we can get those in
um
prior to the next onslaught
of
bills that we have
so um
i am no good at time management
i'm gonna have to i'm gonna have to take
another course in time management but
the problem is you schedule it for an
hour and it goes for three and you
schedule it for
some other amount and it does something
different
so um
we will be back at uh 11 o'clock
to hear
a non-germane amendment
uh
30.
so i will see you then have a cup of
coffee
adjourn
coming back at 11.
do you have a
committee report form that i could use
to turn this into break the minority
report on 422.
oh yeah yeah i think that's yeah yeah
yeah that's good so that's good that's
great
got to get the brain engaged
a couple days later
for the amendment
unless you have it
the second to the amendment
oh
uh
hey dennis
bill frieda ask questions
just
you can pick up you can pick up the uh
i'd like to call this hearing on
non-germane amendment
2022-1703
to order
and i will call on
representative tabers to
introduce the amendment
uh thank you madam chairman just as a
little bit of a background i uh i worked
with uh commissioner sheehan from dot
her staff and the attorneys to come up
with the amendment that's before you a
little bit of also a background
regarding the county you know the coast
is the largest county it's the most
rural we're the only county with two
nursing homes and we're the only county
with no interstate highways so the bill
before you regarding the balsam project
is the hopes that we can get something
going positively for
in in terms of the economy
that being said madam chairman if i
could read the
you know
non-domain amendment so that everybody
will be on board
okay the amendment is on senate bill 401
which is a financial note
it's an act making appropriations of the
department of transportation for local
to the
body
worn in dashboard cameras funds
permitting the department of
transportation to operate dash cameras
in fleet vehicles and relative to the
dixville colebrook road project
amend the bill by inserting after
section 4 the following and renumbering
the original section 5 to read
s6
5 department of transportation dixville
colebrook road project the department of
transportation is authorized to proceed
with the road project named dixville
coburg project number 40518
subject to the following contingencies
roman numeral one
the department of transportation shall
not commence construction on project
number four zero five one eight until
such times that all approvals necessary
for the broad project are received and
financing is secured
roman numeral number two financing must
be sufficient for the redevelopment of
the resort facility and property
formerly known as the boston's grand
resort hotel and for the commencements
of commercial operations at the former
resort facility
roman numeral number three
prior to the construction project of
number four's ando
or county shall execute agreement with
the department agreeing to take
ownership of the road with
responsibility for continuing and
painting certain repairs
room and numeral number four
construction cars shall not exceed 4.1
million dollars
the governor is authorized to draw a
variant
sorry a warrant for the necessary sum
out
out of money in the treasury not
otherwise appropriated
for the construction costs in other
project expenses
the appropriation shall be non-relapsing
project cars shall not be charged the
highway fund
thank you
i will entertain questions but i don't
know if
the answers to all the questions and
my that may be asked i do have people
behind me
in the event that i cannot answer any of
the questions thank you madam chair okay
representative thank you madam chair
thank you representative for taking the
question
um
when the pr
and maybe somebody else will be better
at able to answer this but it talks
about the rog road project being called
dixville colebrook and number 40518.
that means absolutely nothing to me can
you tell me
where that actually applies
as to what it uh
where it well where it applies
where it comes from i can't remember
can't recall however the road project
it's uh part of the road is in dixville
notch which is an unincorporated place
the other part of the road is in the
the
town of colebrook so um that's why it's
called the dixville
gold uh colebrook road project but
i do have the commissioner from the
county behind me who may be able to
better answer that question
representative
thank you that would be helpful thank
you
representative edwards
um thank you uh man i'm sure and thank
you for taking my question um
so
i associate dicksville notch with the
balsams
and we
seemingly the legislature's taken the
position
that the development of
of the balsams should be privately
funded so i'm just curious
how this road project
connects to and supports
the enhancement of the balsams resort
project
and if if this road project is an
appropriate intervention
given a prior decision to have private
capital invested in the balsams
thank you representative the balsams
project
is
well the owners are trying to secure the
appropriate financing as i mentioned
earlier
the road in question in order to
make the baltimore's resort more
amenable and
i guess
better
for
clients to you know
take advantage of those resource the
roads leads up to the golf course
up above
which is a very good golf course it's
the only course in new hampshire that
looks north to canada east of maine and
west of vermont and yet you're still in
vermont
i don't know if i could better answer
that question for you i apologize
representative graham i see that you're
here
mate this was this part of the 10-year
plan
if you don't mind
because
well it's just
it's just because i know thank you madam
chair for the record representative john
graham uh hillsborough seven which is
down to bedford almost the chair of
public works and highways it is not
currently part of the 10-year plan to
answer a previous question that number
the dixon
colebrook project number
five one 40518 is taken from the 2017
version
of the ten year plan which has been
dropped because we weren't going to put
highway funds into
that road
um
so that's kind of where where it is and
it was heard in our
my committee as to whether or not to
include this road in the highway plan as
it was in the senate and both bodies
that deal with
the 10-year highway plan have
elected not to include it in the 10-year
highway plan
at least
this year
and i've got to go back to my seat
i have a question for you representative
graham if i wild
do you want a quick card madam chair
yeah i would like a pink card but uh go
ahead represent
thank you madam chair thank you uh
representative graham um okay so i'm i i
don't do public works i don't do the
10-year transportation plan i if you
could just give me a an easy education
on
the correlation between things that go
into the 10-year plan
and the extent to which that 10-year
plan is sort of
the definitive guideline to what is in
and what is out of our highway planning
the short answer is it starts at the
town and
town level
they work with their regional planners
to come up with a plan for what should
go into
the 10-year highway plan which allocates
both federal and state funds
towards our bridges and roads within the
state state roads not not town roads
then goes through a series of
hearings with
the gasset which is the governor's
council on uh intermodal transportation
and
they
provide a list
a major book to the governor for his
perusal and send to us for for look
we can make changes um
we have in the past
but it is definitive on what the state
intends to spend money on
at least over the next two years until
we do the next ten-year plan
but it it programs things out ten years
so that
we can look at what needs to be done in
the state in a priority listing
of where we are and where we need to
improve our transportation in all modes
it's not just highways
it's uh rail
air
and the rest and
transit also so it's there um so
um it's pretty definitive and as i said
when we looked at this
to find that four million dollars plus
or minus we would have had to take an
another project out of the 10-year plan
because it's fiscally constrained
to fund it and we elected not to do that
go ahead
so so it sounds like this has been duly
considered by the uh duly appointed body
uh it wasn't included
and that this funding would uh be
effectively putting this project to the
front of the line despite having not
gotten there on its own merit
it would be outside of the 10-year plan
representative edwards and that it would
not include
either federal highway funding or state
highway funding ier gas taxes it would
be other funds not appropriated mean in
either surplus or someplace else that
you and the governor could dictate where
it would come from
would it set a precedent maybe
maybe not
but again it depends on how
you look at
wanting to develop
jobs and other things in the north
country and i'm sure you'll hear from
people who are sitting behind me
probably going to hit me outside the
head for
not having said that earlier
uh are there any other questions for uh
representative graham
okay thank you and if you would
would yes i will thank you
thank you
okay uh represent to bears did you have
anything you wanted to add yes uh to
continue as far as the um
i've had a couple of meetings with the
chair of public works and highways
and one of the things that could be done
regarding the 10-year plan is that there
are two things that could be done one
you can ask the municipality to give up
their share of the ten of the road of
the of the monies for the
uh the ten-year plan and give it to the
balsams project
uh that i testified that that was
very very unethical and i would not
request that
secondly i worked with the commissioner
to look at the american rescue plan act
monies for that project
unfortunately the dot funds were only
for transportation and aviation so that
is why i was trying to come up with
another way of securing
funds which may or may not be available
for this project
further questions from representative
burris representative walls
so representation i'm just trying to
understand this the way i read this is
if less saturn gets the money and this
is going forward then there's a road is
that what this is basically this bill
does and without it then there's an
inadequate road to this new development
so this says if we get the development
we're going to have a road that gets you
there if we don't get the development we
don't have to spend the money that is
correct
thank you
are there any further questions
seeing none thank you uh
representative to bears
and i would like to
call
executive councilor joseph kenny
when he finishes filling out his pink
card
yeah i think your mic isn't on just push
morning um so if it says red it's on or
off it's on it's on good
because in my neck of the woods that
means stop
um thank you very much um
to the finance committee um
for letting me speak on behalf of this
amendment
um as you know this project means a lot
to the north country the balsam
redevelopment project has a long history
i mean when i first got to the council
here in 2014
i return a lot of these hearings
discussing how to get funding to help
out this project which is very important
to the north country
and for many years we had um
raise the credit limit to you know to
the bfa to allow for this project
um you know to move forward
unfortunately because of certain things
uh the financial package uh the economy
and the timing it just wasn't right
the developer feels that the timing is
right
this year as he finishes off his
financial package
it's an exorbitantly expensive project
there's no doubt about it in the golf
links road as this amendment is uh
addressing
is um it would allow them to open up
that part
of this project with the the country
club and the beautiful golf courses
and also provide an opportunity
to really develop that side of the
property uh in colebrook as well
we know that the cost of this project
has gone up
from the initial estimates about 2.6
million
to about 4.1 or if not more
um unfortunately we you know it would
have been a nice if we'd done it a few
years ago but costs have gone up and
therefore
uh the amendment is written the way it
is to to reflect that
um there's been a lot of discussions
about
rightly so with the
the commissioner of transportation
and the house committee chairman that we
cannot simply take out
um or put in money
i mean with regards to the 10-year
highway improvement plan
that money is already been programmed
there's money that matches up with these
uh projects
for the next several years and beyond
and and if we do put in the balsams
project
you know into the 10-year highway
improvement plan we'd have to pull
something else out
we've gone too far
through the
the gasset process the legislative
process
to really allow that to happen
because in my judgment
when the regional planning commissions
come together we have the public
hearings all around the state
and we've really kind of haggled and
bargained and figured out what our
priorities are
that we really need to stick to them is
as best we can throughout the
legislative process
and with your work and others we
ineffectively you know have done that
with the 10-year highway improvement
plan i think it's a great plan it
incorporates a lot of additional uh
you know funding for some of our
infrastructure that's going to go a long
ways here in the coming years so
leave that alone
but what we're talking about
is the the authorization of the the
d.o.t commissioner to say listen
if there are other monies that we can
you know access within state government
that this is a project that's going to
have exponential
uh benefit to the north country
you probably heard this thing called the
the hundred millions dollars for this uh
housing program
i never knew there was a hundred million
dollars hanging out there that you know
that we could use for housing so money
is appearing uh quite frequently before
the council
we just passed
umpteen millions of dollars for
the fish hatchery program
another umpteen millions they're going
to go to potentially to the the
hampstead hospital project so
apparently there's a lot of money out
there
but with economic development
infrastructure is key and you can go
right here in concord and look off of
exit 17
with the state um working with the city
of concord over the redevelopment of
exit 17 where there's going to be a
state liquor store there's going to be a
market basket
that the state has put money into it to
support that economic development and
what we're really simply saying with the
balsams project if there's money out
there to support that economic
development project that would create
jobs
absolutely you know
revenue and taxation for property taxes
uh it would create a lot of activity and
vitality uh for that area we know that
the the rubber plant uh
you know rubber plant has taken off
we know like any economic development
project we need housing we need child
care we need in-house counseling
and we and i think the developer
understands that and he has ways of
going about that to create his workforce
and so on so so i don't want to belabor
this but i think if we can provide them
at least a hope or an opportunity that
there might be some money out there to
support this particular road project
other than going into the 10-year
highway improvement plan
that the governor
the legislature
into a certain degree the executive
council
might be able to say okay
let's
you know take care of this state road
bringing up the standards
and pass it over
to the developer
uh into the county of coast because one
thing i've learned about working with
dot for many years
is that
they love relinquishing state roads to
local communities
and to local developers that gets them
off the hook
into the future so this is an
opportunity
that would allow the state to bring up
the road to standards
and then uh relinquish their
responsibility
um to the developer and into the local
community i think it's it's a win-win on
both sides i don't think there's any
really objections to it everybody's just
trying to how do we adhere to the law
that was passed several years ago that
you can't really give money to this
redevelopment of golflinx road
until there's a financial package in
place
and that's still going to stay in place
even if we go out and find money you
know to do this road
we still have to know the developer has
finalized their financial package and
that indeed the development is going to
go forward but from from all indications
there looks like there's a bright future
here
in the near future so without it open up
to any questions
representative
thank you madam chair
uh good morning councilor kenny
i i'm trying to get an executive
overview of
the status of the balsams project i
remember two terms ago when i was here
i believe we passed some uh legislation
that allowed
loans from the state of new hampshire to
the project or whatever what i'm trying
what i'm looking for is what's the
status of the project right now
what is the total estimated cost
absent the road
of the work that auten is doing on the
project what's
what's the total
dollar value of this project does that
make sense yeah no that's excellent
question i know there there's a speaker
too behind me that can give more
specifics you know i can give you kind
of generalizations i know it's so it's
over a 200 million dollar project
um i know that um he's working according
to news reports with goldman sachs he's
working with provident bank he's working
with barclays he's working with a lot of
financial packages he's working with the
county uh with regards to bond issuance
he's working um
with
you know private investors he's
obviously still trying to uh market
uh the various time shares that are
presently on the facility so uh the
financial package is
is wide and long and and the key thing
there has to be a key moment when
everything is synchronized
and meets up at the same time because
remember he's a lot of is being dictated
by the market
so when it comes to bonds so he has to
make sure that there's a healthy uh you
know vibrant market for allow him to
move forward with this project so that's
the best i can give you and i'm not a
financial expert
representative weiler
thank you madam chair
a welcome counselor welcome thank you
i get the impression that this golf
course is a going concern now
how is it accessed now
well if you go
uh to the front entrance of dixville
notch to the balsams you'll see a a long
gate and you're not authorized to go
through that gate however if you do go
through that gate you'll come to a road
further down that that kind of small
entrance road and you will see remnants
of
of the road which i don't know it's a
mile and a half two miles that heads
towards the golf course area of the
country club
it is
a beat up old road that needs a
major improvement if you're gonna have
the the access from the public to going
there and back
and so it's you know it's got a lot of
improvements even if you get the
financing today for this you know
golflinx road you're still going to have
to design engineer it you're going to
have to make sure that you know it's
permitted
there's a lot of wheels
of planning designing and engineering
that have to occur before you're gonna
you know immediately work on that road
so um my judgment of course the
developer probably doesn't want to hear
it for me but i think
the first year you get to financing the
second year to do the project
when it comes to this golf links road
thank you
are there any further questions that
anyone has
you want to follow up
yes man i'm sure okay good
thank you
um and again if you don't if there's
somebody else that can answer the
question better that's fine too but
what is the actual stage of the
construction of the project now am i
assuming there has
to this time this date there is really
no financing lined up at all have they
started what is this status of sure i
think the value in the project right now
is that all the permitting has been done
uh the permitting has been going on for
years and a lot of the permitting has
been renewed
um and you know from the water
withdrawal permitting to
you know some of the dredging you know
uh permitting uh um obviously working
with the cost planning board
all the permits um
that i'm aware of are really in place
and that's where all the money and value
has been put into the project up to this
point
um they're i think they're
probably um
been some upkeep there's been some
development of certain parts of the
project to showcase um what their units
are going to look like in the future
um so there has been a lot of energy and
time expended
um on the sales of trying to you know
get investors committed uh to time
shares and and whatnot
um so um you know if you talk to the
developer you know he'll say he's put
personally seven or eight million
dollars into it um so when you when
you're talking about the development
side of it a lot of it's been the
permitting the planning
and um obviously um the overall
uh concept of the project
and then obviously uh working to get um
sales and investors involved in the
project
thank you very much thank you counselor
glad you could join us thank you
i'll now call on representative edith
tucker
yeah what is your comment
i didn't know
i'm representative
edith tucker from coast five
i didn't know how to fill out a form
so both
uh commissioner gorman and i could speak
together
i should have filled out just one pink
slip apparently no you did fine
thank you um so i will also
welcome uh commissioner gorham
yes
okay
commissioner gorham
is also a selectman in colebrook
and uh
is
most more up-to-date than i am
on exactly where
the
work has gone on the financing package
that the
developer
is close to putting together
there are always obstacles
but
as i said at a previous hearing i almost
can hear the hammer
on the first nail
this is a very important road as you
heard a state road
that has been allowed to deteriorate
over the years
because the resort was not open
and the state had to make choices it was
on the 10-year plan it also was
contingent on getting financing
in the past
that didn't happen it just now appears
that we're are quite close to having
that happen
this road runs from
the main buildings of the ball what was
the balsams resort
uh that mr tillotson owned
and up to a couple of miles up to
the town of colebrook
where
the so-called country club which is a
lovely facility with a
view towards canada vermont new
hampshire as
john harrigan used to say got to see two
foreign countries
vermont being obviously one
and um
it's a donald ross course that has been
maintained
but it's
essential to the hotel that there be
good access
to this
maine
golf
center
and the donald ross course
it also
under the plans that have been developed
would include housing
that would be actually in the town of
colbrook and produce property tax
dollars for the town of colebrook
dixville is an unincorporated place and
has a different arrangement with the
county on how taxes are collected
but i'm here really from coast five
because
all of coast
regrets
the loss of the business
at the balsams hotel
we're losing population
i will lose my seat i no longer will
have a district
we're going to go from 10 reps down to 9
which of course i regret
but it's an ongoing problem that we
don't have
substantial industries on the whole
being developed
in
coast county
this
road project is part of
what would be a very large
project
commissioner gorman
will fill you in on the numbers but i
assure you that
the
lack of a big
amount of activity in that corner of
koas has had devastating effects
on pittsburgh
on colebrook
on berlin on almost all parts of coast
the southern little tear if you think of
it as a crescent
is has not been as affected but i would
say two-thirds of the county has been
adversely affected
by
the closing of the balsams resort
so the idea that we could be so close to
having this happen
and this road being an important part
makes me thank
uh
executive councilor kenny
representative to bears and others for
working to see a way
that we have a plan that is contingent
on the financing going forward
that would then make it possible for
monies to be found in other locations
uh
not from the 10-year plan
to affect
this
repair and
redoing of that important road
so
i'm here really as someone speaking on
behalf of the whole county
now i'm going to turn over the
microphone to
[Music]
commissioner gorman
and
who is also a selectman in colebrook
i really want to thank you folks for
giving me the opportunity to to speak on
this project which means so much to our
whole county
especially the community of colebrook so
i'm going to start from the beginning
because one of the first questions was
what is golf links road
and
golf links road goes directly from the
hotel to the golf course
it is an extreme it is very scenic all
right that whole area we keep talking
about the four states the two countries
it's really scenic okay
and so as you drive up the road you go
approximately let's say a house let's
call it half a mile up golf links road
there's a little pond it's called two
town pond the reason it's called two
town pond is that's the town line of
colebrook and dixville
so the rest of the road is in coburg
okay
leading to the golf course all right so
this road if it is
fixed up
and
made would also be an opportunity for
real estate sales
all right
and then you get to the golf course
which is now two miles away it's a
wonderful clubhouse we used to hold
weddings uh convention parties we used
to do a pile of work there and
um i probably should back up a little
bit i've worked at the balsams for 32
years all right i'm a lifelong resident
of the north country selectmen for
coldbrook and the county commissioner
and so this road
it goes up to the golf course this
incredible stone building uh with this
patio that looks out over the golf
course and into the
other states and so on and so forth so
it really is
the opportunity for the county and for
colebrook also with this golf course and
it's a donald ross course
and it's one of those older courses that
people
travel around the country in the world
to play these courses all right it's a
tough course
you gotta you need a golf cart it's up
the hills down the hills but it's a very
special golf course and they have kept
the golf course
very few people have used it but they've
kept all the greens and they've kept a
crew of five men working on that golf
course ever since the hotel has been
closed for 10 years
realizing the importance of this golf
course
and part of the for colebrook in the
county
the ability that mr ahn is talking about
30 to 50 million in development of
second homes as we like to call them on
around the golf course on this road so
on and so forth
so you can just imagine for a town like
colebrook
to have those type of homes there's
probably not going to be a lot of
students so on and so forth so it would
really for a town that is depressed as
we are
we have a lot of hope right now between
the balsams and app the rubber company
that the council referred to that our
community could really start growing
again after significant losses
in our area through the years with
wausau the paper mill working in growth
and that left my my brother lost his job
there ethan allen going down from five
to 600 people to 100 people i believe
it's on the 80 now um
you know just the in the all of the
balsams closing and and the tillerson
going down we've taken some significant
hits in the last 10 years our population
has dropped valuations of our community
but we're on a
we're on a roll we're gonna we're coming
back the balsams is going to happen app
is providing over 100 job stores
so but the golf links road
it's a real opportunity
for
you know and you think talk about ice
talking about colebrook in the county
but even you guys can look at it as
rooms and meals tax things like that if
you know that's going to be
multi-million the amount of jobs they're
talking about uh a 400 room hotel in
dixville
that would be
you know i think it's approximately 200
million
that is
working with the
goldman and sash and provident group
and the private investors that that mr
auten has lined up as well
on the county level as a county
commissioner i can speak we have 30
million dollars worth of bonds that we
have worked with the legislative bodies
to get the uh unincorporated towns like
in the county so that we can do this
bond
with the developer with mr haughton
and we are full-fledged ahead our
attorneys are working with their
attorneys we just added another advisor
three weeks ago
and were
were full-fledged to had full support
on the county commissioner level all
right and the ability that we have to
support this project all right
uh the town of kolberg has also worked
on our section of gulf links road with
mr arton to to do what he needs there to
develop his project
all right so there's a real
importance here that you can see that
the communities support this and the
ability to add these jobs to add the the
real estate
the whole
package that comes with something of
this size is significant to our
community very significant
i have been part of a process where we
met with commissioner xian
uh mr cass and the the d.o.t folks they
they have been supportive of us all the
way through but this is complex
okay we get the unincorporated we got
the 10-year plan so on and so forth in
at that point uh the commissioner
sheehan was speaking about betterment
funds but now i think that's all
all your monies right now are tied up on
your future projects immediately so
that's why this has kind of gone to a
like a back burner
but now the back burner is on okay
the process is in full
tilt
move forward
hopefully get a shovel in the ground
at least within the next year if not
late this summer or fall
um
and so
i'm more than welcome to take any
questions i can go on i will speak on
this for half an hour but you folks
you've heard enough of me i feel already
but i welcome any questions uh and i can
tell you
i'm passionate about this and i can tell
you my north country folks a large
percentage of them are also i mean this
is hope for us you know this is a real
big thing you know my kids learned to
ski there you know i had as many as
seven members of my family working at
the hotel at the time
it means the balsams was such a special
place and if we can get that going again
where our kids have decent jobs where i
don't know how many of my people that
are my age 60s and 70s that want a
part-time job at the balls it could mean
so much to us
are there any questions for mr gorham
yes representative thank you madam chair
um looking at the the actual map of the
road um
is it safe to assume at this time there
is no
anything else other than at the end
being the golf course in other words
there's no residential development no
houses or anything there right now no
there isn't and and i mean it's you know
you got boulders aside as these tables
you know on the sides of the roads it's
it's mountain it's in there but
in today's world it can happen easily
um the road i would say
as far as use is right right now like
this winter there's so much trail that
goes through there all right and there's
other little roads that go off to um the
ponds all right nathan pond you know um
and
the road itself when the resort is open
there's
50 miles across country trails
all right and you know there's a lot
that can be developed as far as you know
outdoors activities and stuff like that
it would be used
a lot it would be
does that answer the question
yes okay thank you
are there any further questions
i just have one quick question that i'm
not sure that i understood
does golf links road go all the way out
to a road in colebrook
okay so you get the golf links road and
just before the golf course let's say
500 yards there's a broke it continues
it becomes a dirt road and goes into
cobourg
all right goes it goes into cold work
and it goes down through there's
multiple homes an old farm and so on and
so forth so we have worked with mr arden
on that dirt road because i think with
his plans for his houses and stuff he
wanted to change that so we've worked
with him we've already got our attorney
we've taken care of all that so um
is
is that
part of this project
no okay no this is pretty much the
straight shot from the hotel right to
the country club and that's the paved
section this is a pic yeah okay it's a
paved road all right thank you
uh seeing no further questions i will
call on
teresa
rosen
burger
it's a rosenberger
welcome thank you thank you madam chair
and members of the committee i'm theresa
rosenberger i work for bernstein sure
and i'm here representing the balsams
many of you saw me back here in
2014 15 16 etcetera um mr otton
apologizes he could not be here he had a
meeting dealing with the balsams that he
really could not change on short notice
so you get me
um i want to thank representative beers
for putting in the amendment and also
the delegation as well as the county
commissioners for being so incredibly um
supportive as representative wall said
this bill
really authorizes d.o.t
to spend money
on repairing that road just up to the
standards they need in order to pass it
off to the town of the county
what's really important the financial
planning is in place and the permits and
that's really key
that you don't spend a dime unless mr
otton has all of his financing all of
his permits everything's ready and so
that's that's
i think very important from a public
policy point of view um as you know
there have been lots of issues over
these last couple of years this project
we thought was moving forward got slowed
down coveted certainly didn't help
anything at all now it's definitely back
on track
um that he is working with
goldman sachs in the county undoing a
county municipal bond hopefully that
will go to market sometime
depending on the market within the next
ever how many ever how many months
but that's
moving forward this is a complicated
project and
they're just it's a puzzle and there are
a lot of pieces and the road is a really
key part of the puzzle because the state
owns the road and as you've heard people
say you can't get up to the golf course
and the golf course is a key element to
the resort i mean we have issues with
water because we have to do snow making
we have issues with energy because we
have to you know do the do the lifts
we've got financing etc but equally
important is the fact that we need
access to the road and so
this is really giving authority
and we hope you get to spend the money
and i'd be happy to answer answer any
questions i can
are there any questions
for uh
miss rosenberger
representative edwards
um
thank you for uh answering my question i
actually this letter that just got
delivered i i think you're here
representing this the leslie otten the
development and you can speak to what's
in this letter um the way the way i read
this i think this answers an earlier
question i had my question earlier
was
i had understood that the legislative
position was that the balsam resort
needed to be funded through private
capital
and so i was wondering the connection of
between this state road project and that
private capital this letter actually
addresses that what we would be doing as
i understand is we would be bringing
this road up to standard we wouldn't be
gold plating it we would be just meeting
standard right and then upon meeting
standard uh as we do in all cases uh
when we have an ownership transfer we
would then transfer the ownership of
this road to the developer and the
developer would therefore be responsible
forever
it's off your books so so that that that
answers my that question it it brings up
the question though
what if in 10 years the developer uh
defaults or goes bankrupt what what what
happens to the road ownership at that
point
well i think i don't know i will get
back to you on that but i think the
ownership would still stay with the
balsams
because as i understand it what had been
negotiated with d.o.t
and and bea when it was dread way back
in 1415 and 16 was that the state would
bring the road just up to basic
standards transfer it to the county or
the or the
town of colebrook they would then
transfer it to the resort
the develop the development authority
and they would then
own maintain the road as a private road
i'm not sure i totally answered it so
follow up
what i was just asking was for the worst
case scenario and and 10 years after all
of that if uh balsams were to go
bankrupt again
what what would happen to the ownership
of that road well i think the ownership
would stay with the balsams i think i'll
double check but if it once you've
transferred it to the private honor i
think the private owner keeps and
maintains the roads so in bankruptcy if
the has been sold to another development
company or someone it would go with the
package just like the golf course the
golf course etc
are there any further questions
seeing none thank you for oh
of course
representative that's okay thank you
madam chair um
where this project is
200 million plus
and we're looking at
this bill which is talking about we'll
call it four million it can be easy
four million over 200 million that's
less than two percent of a total project
right
has a developer considered possibly
coming up with a
rather than having the
state pay for the 4 million
of the developer adding that into his
total construction costs and maybe
coming up with an agreement with the
state to transfer ownership
after
the road has been brought up to speed i
will get back to you on an answer to
that but it's my understanding that for
the state and this would be a real
question for d.o.t and maybe council
kenny can answer but i think when the
state transfers roads to private
entities or private monitors they have
to be brought up to quote standard
and when this was initially done it was
2.5 million dollars like the project i
think was 1.65 i mean 165 million
well needless to say we've got inflation
but
i think they have to bring it up to
standard whatever that may be now this
is as i understand it a maximum of 4.1
so if
if the state's able to bring it up for
2.5
that that's that's where it is but that
would really be a question for d.o.t i
think
yeah i think what i'm getting
yeah thank you madam chair i think what
i'm getting at is there a
way for the developer the developer to
absorb a the cost of bringing it up to
snuff since that will eventually be
turned over to the
um and i don't know the mechanics of it
maybe he can't do that i don't know but
as
when it's two less than two percent of a
total project why can't that be done by
the developer i will go back and ask mr
otton if that was in the discussions
back in 2014
um as i understand it way back when
the state was doing what i call some
enhancements getting this road back up
to snuff was one of them
in order for the project to go forward
but i'll go back and ask mr otton if it
was if it was discussed
i'll be happy to ask him yeah uh
we need an answer
on that question by tomorrow morning
i will i know his meeting starts at one
so i'll see if i can even get you an
answer before the work session if i can
locate him okay that that's fine we just
yeah yep i'll get you we're in a time
crunch right no i do know that thank you
okay um
[Music]
thank you very much
oh i'm sorry we did have one more
question reps and patch
thank you madam chair just as a matter
of clarity
um the statement was made that the
balsams goes bankrupt again and i don't
believe the balsams went bankrupt i
think the owners chose to close it and i
just would like to interject that as
clarity i think it's kind of important
thank you yeah that that's
that's very true they did not go
bankrupt
okay thank you
uh
representative uh thompson
had uh wanted to testify and
unfortunately he is in a uh executive
committee meeting and so
i apologize that he wasn't able to
get to testify before that occurred
but he will
be part of the record as wanting to
so
i will close
the public hearing
thank you
division one
we have a session going on it's in
recess right now so if you could all
join me in our division one room uh
similarly division three has a meeting
uh that's
to start at 11 30 and we'll be staying
here
um
oh